there's a lot of stuff I don't know
anything about I can't do brain surgery
on you I'm not gonna help you with your
dental problems and I can't work on your
new Maserati I do know about financial
issues it is what I have done for 30
years this is not my first ride on this
cabbage truck and I didn't just wake up
this morning and decide to be obstinate
or hard to get along with on these
stupid PPP loans from the SBA and yet I
think I may be the only one the Ramsey
organization may be the only one and
we're all aligned on this on this panel
that is telling you not to take the in
quotes free money the in quotes grant
because it is neither 100% of the time
that you borrow money and you sign loan
documents you owe the money that's
what's going to happen here then the
question is will the guidelines in the
800 page bill that no one including the
people who voted on it has read will
they allow you without a dadgum federal
loophole to have that loan forgiven so I
got to tell you what we're gonna do at
Ramsey in case you haven't heard before
we don't borrow money because no one's
gonna tell us how to run this business
at a bank ever and I'm not gonna be on
my knees begging the federal government
to do what it promised it was going to
do in the headlines but took away in the
fine print forgiving this loan you're
gonna look up and you're gonna entail at
a minimum a lot of hassle a lot of
hassle and then
be able to get the forgiveness done at a
maximum the forgiveness is not going to
be taken away are the forgiveness is
gonna be taken away in the loan is going
to be still sitting there looking at you
and look you know Daniel tardy we've
heard this from small business leaders
our entire on her leadership career but
Dave you don't understand in our
business we have to borrow money Dave
you don't understand our backs against
the wall well welcome to the frickin
human race right now we all are but you
have to have some things you value what
your principles are and you have to
stand on those principles and good times
and bad times otherwise they're not
principles well Dave one of the things
that I've always admired about you is
you have figured out that there are
principles when proverbs 22:7 says the
rich rules over the poor the borrower is
slave to the lender when you take that
as a principle even when you can
technically justify the specific context
of a situation logically you might can
justify taking the PPP you can go down
the list and say but it's logical that
and it's logical and I can rationalize
this if I want to ignore the principle
but there's some things that are just
worth standing on your conviction on a
timeless principle that is it's based on
whist well let me ask you both this
isn't this a trade-off of short-term
pain because you don't want to have to
let anybody go no leader wants to do
that that's awful you're trading
short-term pain to then have long-term
pain cuz you're gonna be stuck with this
loan over the long haul and Dave Danya
aren't we gonna see a lot of small
businesses that were otherwise healthy
until cash flow stopped strapped
themselves with something that's oh I
just think that's what people aren't
thinking they're not thinking of a
long-term trade-off isn't that the real
problem when they're not thinking about
the fact that they're increasing their
risk they're increasing that they are
now about to be slave to the SBA or the
bank and all these things the Dave's
talking about and so it's not free money
there's no strings attached here's the
thing how many people aren't they're
saying right now and I haven't rubbed
anybody's nose in this publicly anywhere
okay I will admit I have had the thought
but I have not done
I have not done it how many people are
out there saying gosh I wish I had
listened to that stupid Ramsey guy that
I thought was crazy
and I wish right now I was out of debt
and I had an emergency fund in place and
now we're sitting on it sitting here
discussing going into death in the
middle of a time when you're just
supposed to have learned that this crap
doesn't work yeah I mean my god you have
the lessons sitting right in front of
you and then you look to your right and
go I'm gonna borrow money you know it's
just it's so freakin geological it
violates two things one is it tells you
that let me just tell you there's one
time that debt works and that's if
everything works hmm and I have never in
my life in my personal life or in my
business life and I'm old had everything
work the way it's supposed to I can
afford the payments says the guy who
didn't lose his job until the
coronavirus shut down hit mm-hmm and now
I can't afford that car anymore which
means that by the way you couldn't
afford it to start with
and the same is true walking into this
it's like well I mean I could just put
the money in the accountant I can tell
him pay it off and yeah how many times
why did you listen you need to sit down
leaders that are running churches and
you need to take a pay cut or a pay
vacation
by the way Congress you ought to take a
pay vacation and donate all that money
to something because anyway just about
went off on a rabbit hole but anyway the
leaders the first thing that's going to
happen in this in this organization is
the Ramseys will not get paid our names
on the building that's the first thing
that will happen before I lay is sold
off and the second thing will happen is
our leaders in the operating board are
not going to get paid and by the way
they're all okay with that and the third
thing that will happen is we've had a
whole bunch of volunteers at the next
level down that of leadership that says
I'm okay I can make it for 30 days also
get a paycheck too if it means we don't
have to lay people off those are real
leaders they're putting themselves ahead
they're putting their team I had the
team's good ahead of themselves
leadership generally sucks you're
constantly having make bad decisions
with I mean make good decisions with bad
information and partial knowledge of
what's going on and you got to make the
call
anyway it's high-stress people's
feelings are involved and no one
appreciates it but you got to do it
anyway that's what leadership is the
leadership is going first on the hard
things if you don't go you're not you're
not leading it's not going first on the
upside it's going first on the downside
and assuming the risk and absorbing that
so the team doesn't have to right Ken
yeah well I think a lot of people taking
these loans are following everybody else
well everybody else is doing I'm gonna
do it again let's break this thing about
my finesse my planner who makes less
than I make is advising me right my
accountant who you know does not has
never made a payroll in his life except
is one secretary is advising me on how
to run this business no no absolutely
not
do not take these loans out yeah you're
going to create problems that you don't
see yet a hundred percent chance of that
you don't have to be a rocket scientist
to figure this out as my buddy Larry
Chapman says it ain't rocket surgery so
I mean it's just you know guys please
please there's two problems here one is
is that you're counting on debt to be
your supplier you're your provider the
second thing is you're waiting on the
government to be your provider neither
one of these turn out to be good
providers you come up with that is to
create revenues fresh and different and
digitally in the middle of this mess go
do something special and new even if
you're just doing it for 30 days that
you've never done before and you may
never do again cut your own pay preserve
cache preserve cache preserve cache sell
off assets and protect your people
protect your people
that's what you do well and if we have
to furlough them you're gonna cry while
you do it and not take a paycheck to be
clear and you said this this morning in
our meeting you said at the end of the
day if it came down to it after doing
all that and you should do all those
things first we would have to do layoffs
before we take on debt on principle I'm
not one not on principle because I think
it's the shortest way to healing it's
the best way to run an organization
because it's the most profitable and
it's the smartest it's the wisest avoid
the stinking debt please guys please and
you can be mad at me and you make fun of
me some dinosaur if you want but I'm
sitting here freaking open - so shut up